I'm gonna grab something such a complex
character such a slow intuitive
performance
knowing that you've sustained a long
career in modeling which is to be
applauded and I'm sure it wasn't an easy
thing to do what lessons are you taking
from your modeling career that you are
now applying to acting is hard work you
know you know because with modeling like
you know I 12 years you know I started
when I was like I was just about to turn
18 when I started and I worked for a
long time before I got successful but
the job I suppose like hard work and
persistence and showing up and you know
you know doing doing the job to the best
of my ability in the space that's what I
want to do with this as well well I like
to what you said in another interview
you said that sometimes you you had
other interests and you didn't take it
too seriously which is probably a really
smart thing because so many people do
become ultra focused on it and it
consumes them do you have other outside
interests like filmmaking even yeah I
suppose I can I have a life doc marten
it's like a design clothes when she use
and stuff and yeah I suppose I'm gonna
get starting to you know explore that in
a creative way of you know doing those
short films right now and because they
were lovely I'm sorry
by young people especially like your
women of this generation that's coming
up and their strength and that's I kind
of I would like to capture that yeah
well is there a certain character that
you watched where you said I want to do
that that's what I want to do is there a
certain film of a female rule even a
manual where you said wow that character
really affected me and I you know the
the gender Bart may be a silent movie
yeah if that was so powerful you know to
me to watch and I think I watched that
and it was like especially like because
of the music and stuff it was like a
real like like crazy kind of like
experience you know like so like in
there
I suppose I riddle it just kind of like
what to not and I remember watching that
being like wow this is intense
yeah can you need some things that when
you see a film you automatically feel
connected sometimes there's films where
maybe there's a disconnect from the
characters are there films that you've
seen where you feel also connected to
the characters and do you know what that
element might be I think trace you know
you're like you know you want to go on
this journey with someone
it has to be true do you know what I
mean so I think my truth you know and
that's that's what I want when I watch a
movie I want to be taken on this journey
and I want to like be like you know the
feeling have been punched in the stomach
because it was like affected you so much
I think that yeah like truth and being
in the moment is you know it's opposed
one thing that you know when I watch
someone that like wow because you kind
of forget you're watching a movie and
you mentioned another in another
interview that you've been around the
world and you've seen so many things and
experience different cultures what
lessons from your travels have you taken
to delightful I mean what what things
have affected you that you kind of take
with you is that part of the not taking
something - seriously realizing there's
a bigger picture yeah I suppose seen
different cultures and realizing how big
the world is and that not that like an
individual is so small but like stuff
isn't as important as you know like you
know high-class problems like you know
it becomes like less effective you know
the main like when you realize that how
much is going on in the world right in
this moment you know kind of may
like I think you create such like a
freedom in a way and not being say like
co-op on stuff I think I find that the
more and more like my vision my widens
to the world I feel like less hung up on
stuff
I've read a few places that you've been
compared to a chameleon in some way so
they're different looks and modeling are
you able to seek that into acting as
well
these were communion and having many
different personalities yeah I suppose
so I suppose you know even in Pasha you
know she has like she has these two
things going on it's like she's two
different people and you know you relate
to that you know when you go into
different situations it's like as if
like you've physically changed and
Genaro mean like sometimes when you go
to certain situation your body human
changes and everything so yeah
whatever's going on inside kind of like
helps that also like you know like a
status basically you know as well but
you know if like that was the thing that
was drawn to with her you know because
of you know how she's like this like you
know delicate flower that's such like a
romances and a dream
and like at work she's like this like
you know look at me like I'm a woman
kind of my you know this power so that
was like exciting to play did you do
certain things to prepare for that well
did you maybe you do did you watch the
people and and sort of say their
characteristics or what did you do oh I
read a lot of books and watched a lot of
movies you know books on the dances are
written addicts had written to get some
reality on it then like literally go in
finding those people you know like
speaking to you know heroin addicts drug
addicts and people that works in the
profession of dancing and stripping
going to work with those people and
getting getting in their lives and
trying to create flow in in a real way
you know you know especially like the
scenes you know where she's like
shooting up and everything like that I
wanted to I wanted it to be so natural
you know so and that was really
interesting because I had this the more
and more you explore different people
everyone's the same at the end of the
day
you know like everyone has like these
urges to you know survive but they have
all this stuff that's going on in their
life that you know creates that path for
them and I think the Lewis you know
wanted to translate that in the Mundi
that you know you could be any of these
characters you know you can have like
something happen in your life where you
have to make a decision works like I
have to do this or I do this for
survival so and yeah I feel like you
really captured that you know you go
away and you love everyone you know you
empathy you could be my loan you could
be Hakam you know you could be Flo I'll
Frank you know and you can relate to all
of them no matter what they do you know
what their inherent like you know what
like the evilness of the guys you know
it's you still feel for them and know
like you can have a reaction like like
that's so not you you know so you
actually went into certain environments
and sort of like a fly on the wall yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was so interesting you
know especially like going working with
Jan this girl he was so generous in
stuff like being you know being in her
world she works you know and also
own life as well and her like being like
yeah just come with me like do whatever
you want whatever you need like tell me
you know and so generous in teaching me
about that but I you know dancing and
teaching me how to dance and like
literally being with her while she was
like doing that job and it was so
interesting and so so creative that job
as well you know she Sai acts in a role
as well and that helpful flow as well
because I feel like she has to do that
in life she has to act a certain way
because of the fear of that what she has
at home you know that vulnerability so
anybody know the ranks I suppose I am
the same you know the same as other
girls the women that start in a career
in acting you know space you know fun
like I had so much fun and they want to
do things where I am